>>> YOU MIGHT REMEMBER HIM AS
RYAN AT WOOD, THE ROUGH AND
TOUGH KID WHO FOUND HIMSELF
LIVING AMONG THE WEALTHIEST
FAMILIES IN ORANGE COUNTY IN THE
2000 CLASSIC "THE OC."
>> NO WAY.
LOOK WHO'S BACK.
A LITTLE FAR FROM EIGHT MILE.
>> LUKE, DON'T.
>> WHAT ARE YOU?
LIKE THE SPOKESPERSON FOR GEEKS
OF AMERICA OR SOMETHING?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I LIKE ABOUT
RICH KIDS?
NOTHING.
>> THESE DAYS ACTOR BEN McKENZIE
IS TAKEN OUT A DIFFERENT ROLE AS
A CRITIC OF CRYPTOCURRENCY HE
SAYS DRIVEN COMPLETELY BY
SPECULATION.
>> THE SUPPOSEDLY MULTITRILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY WAS NOTHING MORE
THAN A MASSIVE SPECULATIVE
BUBBLE BOUND TO POP.
IN MY OPINION, THE
CRYPTOCURRENCY INDUSTRY
REPRESENTS THE LARGEST PONZI
SCHEME IN HISTORY.
IN FACT, BY THE TIME THE DUST
SETTLES, CRYPTO MAY WELL
REPRESENT A FRAUD AT LEAST TEN
TIMES BIGGER THAN MADOFF.
>> HE TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
SENATE BANKING COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY IN ITS INVESTIGATION
INTO THE COLLAPSE OF THE FTX
CRYPTO EXCHANGE.
SENATOR JOHN TESTER WAS ASKED BY
A REPORTER AFTER IF CONGRESS
COULD HAVE HELPED PREVENT THE
SUDDEN COLLAPSE OF FTX.
>> I DON'T KNOW, BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW THAT ANYBODY FULLY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE HELL CRYPTO
EVEN IS.
>> JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS IS
THE ACTOR AND CO-AUTHOR OF "EASY
MONEY," BEN McKENZIE.
BEN, YOU HAVE BEEN WARNING ABOUT
THE DANGERS OF THIS FOR SOME
TIME NOW.
YOU EVEN TOOK A 24-PART ONLINE
COURT WITH SEC CHAIR GARY
GENSLER ON THIS.
I WONDER IF YOU'VE BEEN PROVEN
RIGHT.
>> YES.
I DO FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN PROVEN
RIGHT.
I STARTED WARNING PEOPLE IN
OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR.
THE MARKET PEAKED IN NOVEMBER,
SO JUST A MONTH AFTER JACOB
SILVERMAN, MY COLLEAGUE AND I,
WROTE OUR FIRST BOOK, WARNING
CELEBRITIES ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
THESE CRYPTOCURRENCIES AND
WHATNOT.
SINCE THEN, THE MARKET HAS LOST
70 TO 75% OF ITS VALUE.
THAT'S JUST THE VALUE ON PAPER.
CRYPTOCURRENCY IS THIS OPAQUE,
LARGELY UNREGULATED MARKET.
SO YOU CAN'T EVEN FEE IF THE
NUMBERS ARE REAL.
>> I WONDER HOW YOU THINK YOU
SAW THIS WHEN SO MANY OTHER
CELEBRITY HAVE BEEN PUSHING IT,
HAVE BEEN HAWKING IT,
ENCOURAGING THEIR FANS TO GET
INVOLVED IN THIS.
HOW WERE YOU SO SKEPTICAL OF IT
IN THE FIRST PLACE?
>> I HAVE A DEGREE IN ECONOMICS.
I LIKE TO SAY THE BOOK I'M
WRITING IS ABOUT MONEY AND
LYING.
I KNOW ABOUT MONEY FROM MY
ECONOMICS DEGREE AND FROM MAKING
A LITTLE BIT OF IT WITH 20 YEARS
IN SHOWBIZ.
I KNOW ABOUT LYING BECAUSE I DO
IT FOR A LIVING.
AS AN ACTOR, YOU'RE AWARE OF
WHAT PEOPLE ARE DOING AND HOW
THEY'RE USING LANGUAGE.
LANGUAGE IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT WE DISCOUNT
TO OUR PERIL.
WHEN CRYPTOCURRENCIES CALL
THEMSELVES CURRENCIES, THEY ARE
NOT CURRENCIES BY ANY REASONABLE
ECONOMIC DEFINITION.
THEY ARE IN STEAD SECURITIES,
MEANING INVESTMENTS.
BUT THEY'RE UNREGISTERED,
UNLICENSED SECURITIES.
WE'VE ACTUALLY TRIED THIS.
IN THE 1920s, THE ROARING '20s
BEFORE THE GREAT CRASH OF 1929
AND THE DEPRESSION, WE DIDN'T
HAVE FEDERAL SECURITIES LAWS.
IT'S PRETTY IRONIC THAT 100
YEARS LATER WE'RE REVISITING
THAT ERA.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAPPENS IS A
LOT OF PEOPLE GET SUCKED IN AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE LOSE MONEY.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE, A LOT OF
REGULAR PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT IS AT THE HEART OF
THIS.
SOMETHING YOU SAID WHEN YOU WERE
TESTIFYING IS BASICALLY YOU
BELIEVE THE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN DRAWN INTO THIS HAVE
BASICALLY JUST BEEN SOLD A BILL
OF GOODS.
>> THEY HAVE.
THE LIES ARE BOTH BIG AND SMALL.
THE FIRST LIES START WITH
LANGUAGE, BUT THEY DO GET
BIGGER.
ROBERT SCHILLER, THE NOBEL PRIZE
WINNING ECONOMIST HAS TALKED
ABOUT HOW ECONOMIC NARRATIVES
FORM.
THEY'RE STORIES IN RESPONSE TO
REAL THINGS.
THE CREATION OF CRYPTO IS A
RESPONSE, SUPPOSEDLY, TO THE
SUBPRIME CRISIS.
THE HUGE DEBACLE THAT CREATED A
LOT OF UNDERSTANDABLE MISTRUST
OF OUR FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
HAS GIVEN CRYPTOCURRENCY THE
STORY A LOT OF ITS POWER.
EVERYONE KNOWS WE HAVE BIG
PROBLEMS IN THIS COUNTRY, A LOT
OF PROBLEMS WITH OUR REGULATED
FINANCIAL SYSTEM.
CRYPTO SAYS, OH, WE CAN FIX ALL
THAT.
WE CAN BANK THE UNBANKED, BUILD
GENERATIONAL WEALTH, IT'S THE
FUTURE OF MONEY, IT'S THIS, IT'S
THIS, IT'S THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROBLEM IS
THAT ALL OF THOSE STORIES ARE
NOT TRUE.
NONE OF THEM ARE TRUE.
YOU SEE NOW UNFORTUNATELY,
ALMOST WHEN IT'S TOO LATE THE
POWER OF THOSE LIES.
PEOPLE WANTED TO BELIEVE IN IT
SO MUCH, AND I UNDERSTAND WHY,
THAT THEY GOT SUCKED IN.
NOW UNFORTUNATELY 40 MILLION
AMERICANS, THE VAST MAJORITY OF
40 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE LOST
MONEY.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU
HEAR SOMEONE LIKE SENATOR TESTER
SAY I DON'T THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE EVEN KNOW WHAT CRYPTO IS.
WHEN IT'S LAWMAKERS AND THEIR
ROLE THAT THEY COULD HAVE BEEN
PLAYING HERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY NEED TO
DO DIFFERENTLY?
>> WELL, IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING.
WHEN YOU TALK TO THE 80-PLUS
PERCENT OF THE COUNTRY THAT HAS
NOT BOUGHT CRYPTOCURRENCY, THEY
ALMOST SAY THE SAME THING.
I'VE BEEN TRAVELING AROUND THE
WORLD AND TALKING ABOUT THIS
WITH LOTS OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE
FROM SAM BANKMAN-FRIED HIMSELF
TO OTHER INVESTORS.
PEOPLE ALWAYS SAY THE SAME
THING, OR ALMOST ALWAYS.
THEY SAY I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND IT BUT IT SEEMS KIND
OF SCAMMY.
I SAY NO, NO, NO, YOU GOT IT.
IT'S NOT REALLY THAT
COMPLICATED.
BLOCKCHAIN, THIS SUPPOSEDLY
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY, IT'S A
LEDGER.
IT'S A WAY OF STORING
INFORMATION.
IT'S REALLY NOT REVOLUTIONARY.
IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR 30 YEARS,
IT GOES BACK TO AT LEAST 1981
WHEN THE FIRST BLOCKCHAIN WAS
CREATED.
BLOCKCHAIN IS A LEDGER.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS THEY'RE
USING IT TO SELL YOU ON A STORY
THAT IT'S THE FUTURE OF MONEY.
IRONICALLY ENOUGH, IT'S ACTUALLY
THE PAST OF MONEY.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT AT PRIVATE MONEY
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE TRIED IN
THE 19th CENTURY AND IT FAILED.
IN PART IT FAILED BECAUSE OF
FRAUD.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE STORIES,
BUT AS I KNOW AS A STORYTELLER,
JUST BECAUSE IT'S A STORY
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S A TRUE STORY.
>> THAT'S A REALLY GOOD POINT.
YOUR TESTIMONY WAS REALLY
IMPACTFUL.
EVERYONE SHOULD WATCH IT.
BEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING.
>> IT WAS MY PLEASURE.
THANK YOU.
>> THAT WAS SUCH A GREAT
CONVERSATION.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, SMART
GUY, GREAT ACTOR.
>> SAW ALL OF THIS BEFORE IT
HAPPENED.
>> WHAT HE SAID ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THAT WE TRIED THIS
BEFORE IS A VERY IMPORTANT P